hey 42 here i'm going to go out on a
limb here and guess that you've probably
heard of the knight templar despite
apparently having been disbanded getting
on for a millennium ago this secretive
order of christian warrior monks remains
surprisingly prominent in the public
consciousness cropping up in video games
tv shows novels and films with
impressive regularity
perhaps that has something to do with
the widespread rumors that the night
templar never really went away and that
the remnants of this secret order
continue to pull the strings of society
from the shadows even today
whatever the reason it's clear the
knights temblor have gotten themselves
tangled up with a huge range of myths
and legends over the centuries from the
holy grail to the ark of the covenant
and the founding of the freemasons
but as exciting as all these conspiracy
theories are this is one of those rare
cases where the true story is every bit
as interesting as all the probably made
up stuff because from incredibly humble
beginnings and in a startlingly short
space of time the real night templar
rose to become one of the most
influential organizations in history
during their meteoric rise the templar
attained unimaginable wealth broke new
boundaries in the business world and
wielded the kind of power that makes
even kings jealous
but as is often the case with rapid
rises the fall of the night templar was
if anything even more spectacular ending
with one of the most powerful men on
earth being burnt at the stake in the
shadow of notre dame cathedral whilst
spitting curses like kanye west on a
diss track
but
i'm guessing ahead of myself
to best tell the story of the knights
templar i should probably start at the
beginning
a beginning that can be found almost a
thousand years ago in 1119 a.d exactly
20 years after the franks captured
jerusalem from the fatimid caliphate
during the first crusade
with jerusalem suddenly under christian
control
christian pilgrims from all across
europe began flocking to the holy land
to visit the many sacred sites found
there
but these pilgrimages were dangerous
whilst the city of jerusalem itself was
well guarded
much of the rest of the holy land which
stretches from the mediterranean sea to
the banks of the river jordan
wasn't
bandits were common and pilgrims were
easy targets
thousands were robbed or even killed
[Music]
sickened by this wanton slaughter a
french knight by the name of hughes
depends decided to transform himself
into the hero the holy land needed
so he gathered together eight of his
nightly mates and with the blessing of
king baldwin ii of jerusalem
formed a new monastic order with the
sole aim of protecting christian
pilgrims on their travels around the
holy land
to begin with that's all it was a few
brave knights chaperoning pilgrims
despite having been given shiny new
headquarters on temple mount in
jerusalem by the king himself
the knights were incredibly poor relying
on the charity of those they protected
to survive
their lack of funds along with the
location of the headquarters actually
inspired their original name the poor
knights of the temple of king solomon
but that was a bit of a mouthful and so
eventually it was shortened to the name
that remains so famous even today the
night templar
this small band of warrior monks did
their protection job exceptionally well
and soon enough their reputation in
christendom began to grow helped in no
small part by the fact that one of the
original knights had a nephew who was
going places in the catholic church and
when i say going places he was
eventually made a saint
when he talked catholics listened before
long the knights templar were the
trendiest charity in town and anyone who
was anyone suddenly wanted to be seen
supporting them some donated cold hard
cash others left land or valuables to
the templars in their wills
and noble families started sending any
spare male sons they had lying around to
join the order and make a name for
themselves
by 11 35 a.d even the pope was feeling a
bit of fomo which he quenched by issuing
the templars with a large monetary
donation
four years later he passed a papal order
that made the templars exempt from
paying taxes and essentially put them
outside of local law
in whichever countries they operated in
in short they were answerable only to
the pope himself
[Music]
from there the power and popularity of
the templars continue to snowball
at their peak they were fought to be as
many as 20 000 members spread across
pretty much the whole of europe and the
middle east but the templars never let
this success go to their heads the life
of a knight was heavily regimented and
restricted
all new inductees were made to take vows
of poverty chastity piety and obedience
they also had to follow several hundred
strict rules that dictated how they
should lead their day-to-day lives
these rules were incredibly prescriptive
outlining what the knights could eat
how they should spend their free time
and what they could wear
most importantly of all the rules made
it clear that the knights were to avoid
fraternizing with women at all costs
all that pent up sexual frustration
seems to have paid off because the
knights had a truly fearsome reputation
on the battlefields of the holy land
they excelled to such an extent that
they evolved from pilgrim protectors to
an elite corps of heavily armored shock
troops that were deployed wherever the
fighting was fiercest throughout the
crusades
the knights were well trained and
expensively armed but
it was their bravery that really stood
out
they were forbidden from retreating in
battle unless every single templar flag
on the field had fallen
it helped that dying in battle was seen
as a great honor granting the fallen
knight automatic q-jump privileges at
the gates of heaven as a result the
templars showed no fear even in the most
hopeless of situations
away from the battlefields of the holy
land things were going equally well for
the order which had become so rich so
quickly it hardly knew what to do with
all that cash eventually the templars
settled on basically doing everything
real estate was one of the biggest
focuses as well as buying up huge waves
of land in europe and the middle east
they built castles and cathedrals by the
hundreds many of which still stand to
this day they bought up vineyards
farmland and stables got involved in
manufacturing and hired blacksmiths
builders and squires
they also bought a large fleet of ships
and most impressively of all the entire
island of cyprus
off the back of all these achievements
and more
some modern historians consider the
knights templar to have been the world's
first multinational corporation
one of the most successful aspects of
this business empire was dedicated to
what can be considered as a prototype of
the modern concept of international
banking
the system started out as an innovative
way to help christians with the
logistics of visiting the holy land a
pilgrim could head to a templar house in
their home country before setting off
to hand over their valuables or cash in
return for a letter of credit
that credit could then be withdrawn from
any other templar house anywhere else in
the world
it was actually kind of ingenious not
only did it give the templars another
way to make money it also helped them
with their original mission of
protecting christians in the holy land
because since pilgrims no longer had to
carry valuables with them on their trip
to jerusalem they became far less
attractive to bandits
over time the financial services offered
by the templars expanded to include the
pawning of valuables money lending and
even the paying of ransoms on credit
these services were so highly regarded
they were used by some of the most
powerful people in europe at the time
including at least two kings king henry
iii of england is said to have pawned
his crown jewels with the templars in
order to raise some quick cash to help
quell an uprising amongst his barons and
king philip iv of france borrowed
significant sums from the templars to
finance a series of expensive wars
mostly with the english well it was
pretty much always the english
somehow in under 200 years what had
started out as nine poverty stricken
nights protecting pilgrims on the road
to jerusalem had grown into a
multinational conglomerate with the
power of a small country
the trouble was whilst the templars had
the riches and influence of a nation
they didn't actually control one and
that meant their entire existence
relied on the goodwill of the men who
did
the kings of europe unfortunately for
the templars that goodwill was about to
abruptly run out
it started with the fall of jerusalem to
legendary general saladin and his armies
in 1187.
the christians did manage to regain the
city again in 1229 but they lost it
again 15 years later
jerusalem would remain under muslim
control for the next 700 years
the templars had diversified admirably
in the years since their foundation
but at their core they existed to fight
for christianity in the holy land
with that land now under new ownership
for the first time since their formation
people began to question whether or not
the knights templar really were
necessary anymore by this point they
should have been big enough and powerful
enough to shrug that kind of criticism
off
and they probably would have done had
their own success not come back to bite
them at the worst possible time i
mentioned a moment ago that philip iv
for france had borrowed money from the
templars to fight the english
what i didn't mention is that he
borrowed a lot of money
so much in fact that paying it all back
was proving to be a bit of a problem
luckily for philip iv he was a king and
kings have always had their own unique
ways of dealing with problems
usually by murdering them
seizing on the shifting public sentiment
towards the templars king philip put
together a list of heresies he claimed
were being committed by the secretive
templars in their castles and cathedrals
those heresies included spitting and
urinating on the cross
worshiping false idols specifically
baphomet and engaging in homosexual
activities
it was mostly [ __ ] obviously
well apart from that last one you can't
build a secret order of twenty thousand
men who are all forbidden to fraternize
with women without things getting at
least a little bit broke back mountain
but king philip wasn't worried about the
veracity of his claims anyway all he had
to do was find a few prominent templars
willing to confess to the crimes they
were accused of and his case would be
water tight and no templar was more
prominent than jax to malay the grand
master and leader of the entire order
you might think it would be difficult to
get the brave knights templar to admit
to crimes they hadn't committed
but remember this was a long time ago
before trifling things like human rights
existed if you were a king and you
wanted someone to confess to something
he didn't do all you had to do was
torture him for a bit and you were
golden sure enough jackster malay along
with many of his knights confessed to
everything
many would later recant their
confessions once free from the thumb
screws
but by then it was too late the templar
name had been tarnished and under
pressure from king philip the pope
instructed that every template in europe
should be arrested and put on trial
a few years later the order was
officially disbanded
hundreds perhaps thousands of templars
were killed for their supposed crimes
including jacks to malay who king philip
had burnt at the stake on an island in
the middle of the river sen in paris
it said that malay cursed both the pope
and king philip even as the flames ate
him alive
vowing that divine retribution will be
brought down on both of them in short
order
and it seems that guy knew how to
execute a solid curse because both the
pope and king philip were dead within
the year
not that it made any difference to the
templars their race was officially run
those that escaped prosecution joined
other catholic military orders or simply
retired
never to raise arms again in the name of
god
or at least that's the official line but
of course plenty of people believe the
templars never truly went away and for
why that is well that's a good question
and there's no simple answer in truth
there's little evidence to support
pretty much any of the many myths and
legends that surround the templars today
when the organization was disbanded it
left behind a huge void
and over the years people have filled
that void with many stories most of the
myths are linked to the mystery of what
happens to the templars vast wealth
after their demise
but there's actually a pretty simple
answer to that one king philip iv
happened to it
appropriating templar funds to pay off
his mountainous debts
most other european kings did the same
these days many people and organizations
around the world claim to be descendants
of the knights templar including the
freemasons but almost all of them are
just appropriating the templar story
because it sounds cool
let's be honest the vast majority of
so-called knights templar knocking
around today are just middle-aged men
with overactive imaginations who think
they look good in chainmail
that isn't quite the end of the story
though because there is actually one
modern organization that genuinely is
linked to the templars
the military order of christ based in
portugal
you see whilst the various kings of
europe were arresting templars left
right and center by order of the pope
one king
dennis of portugal refused
instead he set up the military order of
christ and invited any surviving
ex-templars to join it
the group still exists today more than
700 years later
but sadly there's no reason to believe
they're hiding the holy grail the ark of
the covenant or jesus and mary
magdalene's great great great great
great great grandchildren
sorry to disappoint you dan brown the
templar's legacy lives on in many other
ways though they did so much building at
the height of their power that many
templar landmarks still exist today
temple the legal district in london is
named for the templars along with
literally hundreds of churches and
castles throughout europe and the middle
east the templars may be gone at least
in their original form
but they certainly haven't been
forgotten and if you ask me the
countless myths and conspiracy theories
that surround the order are surplus 2
requirements the actual documented
history of these brave warrior monks is
better than all of them anyway
[Music]
thanks for watching